what makes a great story what makes a
great story you know Karen that question
it's huge that's what drives this entire
industry is what makes a great story I
think a couple of things for me and it
has to be personal because I think
different people have different opinions
of what is a great story or a great film
or whatever was a great story is a story
about a very ordinary human being who's
faced with extraordinary challenges and
goes through an extraordinary
transformation trying to survive or get
back to where they were or to find their
way to some new place so there's a
journey there's a great journey that
that person personally goes on to me
that that's what makes a great story
great story to me is a story about
relationships about the struggle this is
obviously very personal because this is
my preference the struggle in
relationships not just the struggle of
the two individuals or three or four
individuals and trying to achieve what
they want to achieve but the struggle we
all have as human beings just relating
to each other and being open with each
other being honest with each other
getting what we want from each other
giving what we want to each other
forming some kind of relationship and
how difficult that is how perilous it is
how fragile it is and how quickly it can
fall apart a good example of that is
marriage story which is not which is
like a beautiful wonderful happy
marriage which is falling apart and
sometimes at least my experience
watching that film why why is it falling
apart
well because it's that fragile and I
think that you know there wasn't a big
violation in the middle of it that
created this falling apart those kind of
stories are what make for me make great
stories then in the story telling the
telling of the story what makes a great
story is when I'm surprised I love it
when I'm surprised
there's a point where the story's going
on and what we all do when we see a
story happening is we all in our minds
consciously or unconsciously anticipate
or predict where it's gonna go eyal I
can see where this is gonna go this is
gonna happen or because he did that
she's going to do that oh I can see it
and many times we're right but then
there are those moments when it just
does a total reversal and we didn't see
it coming we didn't see it coming and
what that does those moments those
turning points that are so startling
understandable but startling just I'm
not expected and then they're not
magical it's not science fiction or I
think like that's just not expected that
moment opens up something for us and
where we can see deeper into who those
characters really are so we get greater
insight into these characters and their
struggles and their problems and that's
the beauty of a well told story
why do you think some people resonate
with one story over another so someone
could see what we sound like we both saw
Judy we both liked it I thought it was
was excellent as tragic as it was mm-hm
but some other people could see it and
say yeah I'm not impressed what do you
think one person thinks a story is great
versus another season says nothing
special well I think it all comes to and
else you and I have had this a couple of
times so I will sit side by side at a
movie and I'll share who was right over
here
Elsa will love the movie and I don't or
vice versa
now it's only because we're two
different people that it doesn't it's
still the same it's still the same movie
still it's the same story but getting
back to your question why what makes why
do people resonate with certain stories
I think it all comes down to projection
because as we're watching a story one
thing I'm very keenly aware of for
myself and for everybody else when we
watch a story we project ourselves into
the other characters in fact and we do
it when we read a script or read a novel
we do the same thing but when we watch a
movie we do the same we project
ourselves and the way we
dissipate in the portrayal of that
character we get involved with that
character we care we have empathy or we
have discussed we have some kind of
emotional connections with each
character and so we go on the journey
with them now if we watch a movie like
Judy and someone watches that and
there's no way for that individual who's
watching it to project himself or
herself into that character because
there's no common ground there's nothing
not that you have to be an actress or a
singer or in Hollywood but do you aspire
to do anything artistic do you have you
know these demons that is there anything
within if there's nothing within that
character that they can project
themselves into and attach themselves to
then they're not going to like the film
because it is not speaking to them
nothing wrong with the film it just
doesn't speak to them and they could
like another film like a transformer
film which they think is brilliant and I
could go I don't get it because that I
can't project myself into that world so
there's a world and there are characters
that we have to project ourselves into
and get involved and engaged with and if
we can't then we'll just sit back and
watch the movie and wonder what the
whole fuss is all about
you